before we go any further potential
spoilers ahead you have been warned I
thought that I was the only one who had
a problem with this until I saw a post
on the Starfield subreddit it says I
never hated anything so much in a game I
love so much and it's a reference to the
weird rooms that you just sort of jet
pack around in the temples I put a lot
of time into this game I finished the
main quest and honestly I feel like I
spend so much time in these and still
don't really know if I'm doing it right
like it seems like you boost towards the
glittery thing faster and it'll finish
faster if you get there faster but
there's like no context for why that's
the mechanic or why you're doing that
it's not different based on the power
which would be much nicer and it doesn't
have the cool appeal they had in Skyrim
or at least you're like trying to
overcome a challenge you just sort of
mindlessly boosting towards something
for some reason it's a really weird
choice I don't know does everyone feel
this way about it or am I missing
something